hello
I think I'm jealous is that what I'm
feeling
[Music]
cauldron Singapore I hope you're doing
well I'm well thank you hi thank you so
Nikki is amazing I love her so far but
there's so so much about her that we
don't know yes outside would be
Jennifer's best friend and a paralegal
what is Nikki all about like what is his
story Nikki is definitely about you know
she's a very free person who knows who
she is you know so she'll love anyone
she wants she'll throw herself into any
situation that she wants I look at her
as someone who's been through so many
things as all women have and all women
of color you know and she's kind of
landed at this place where she knows
exactly who she is and she doesn't give
up you know so she's she's just uh
surviving and she's having fun doing it
and she's uh she's she's really there to
kind of um to keep things light and be a
wonderful cheerleader for uh people to
reach their full potential you know I
love that about her I love how she's so
confident too and she's a completely new
character so like what about her made
you want to take on the role and how did
Marvel pitch this character to you well
so it was um when you auditioned for
anything in Marvel it's so secretive so
you don't really know what you're just
reading lines you know you don't even
know if it's actually from the script or
whatever and you can try to do your
digging but you'll be wrong I I think at
some point I thought I was auditioning
for some new version of the WASP you
know all I knew is that she was high
fashion and so I was like I did some
search and I think that at one point the
WASP was a costume designer for She-Hulk
and something so I'm like ah I guess
they're redoing the WASP I guess I'm
gonna start flying
um so but uh but in my audition
I uh I improvised a lot and so I kind of
just I took the law because you don't
know what you're auditioning for and the
lines are kind of just they're there and
they're funny and they're cool I really
made it my own and I I improvised a lot
and I played like kind of a a weird
version of whatever it was intended to
be and then because of that they they
kind of they made a new character and
called her Nikki Ramos and then really
uh started writing for me you know the
scripts were written but they adjusted
it so that so that I could be this new
new character so I got to to Really uh
insert myself into how uh how she would
be and and and uh yeah and I'm so
grateful to to everyone Jessica GAO and
Kat koiro who who read the lines and
thought of me for it so it's really
exciting so like what are her powers
Nikki yeah Mickey's I joke that thank
you I know a joke that Nikki's biggest
power is to not be in the largest amount
of credit card debt ever based off all
the clothes that she buys
um but I think her power is just like
her insane amount of freedom in her life
and her and bravery you know like she
has an unlimited resource for being like
I can make it happen or no that doesn't
scare me or I'll get this done you know
like I she's and because of that she's
always able to like get Jen into a
little little bit of trouble and she's
always Nikki is always willing to do
things that are kind of borderline
illegal or maybe you know things that
Jen wouldn't do but it's like don't you
worry about it I'll get it covered so uh
I love how Reckless she is in a way
where she for some reason always thinks
that she's gonna land on her feet and
always knows how to charm her way out of
any situation you know and she can hang
with anyone so I think her superpower is
like how much she gets people and I
think also uh I think she understands
kind of human psychology a lot and so I
tried to incorporate that in a lot of
the later scenes you'll see how she kind
of just like always understands people
whether they're good or bad and then she
can hang with them yeah
please